this is sort of motivated by the demise
of the herschel space observatory
recently came to the end of its mission
and it was orbiting in a slightly
strange orbit at a thing called the l
two point and so since we're supposed to
be doing symbols here there's a nice
symbol here l with a little subscript
two after it for the l for lagrange
point and two because it's the second of
five of these points
it's helpful to think about these things
in terms of where you'd want to put
satellites into orbit and in the context
of missions like the herschel
observatory it was a an infrared
telescope which means that you wanted to
get it away from the earth because the
earth radiates huge amounts of infrared
radiation so trying to do this science
from a low earth orbit would be really
like trying to do astronomy with all the
light switched on because basically the
earth is glowing brightly in these
wavelengths so what you want to do is
you want to get the satellite away from
the earth but that law leads to all
sorts of problems of its own because if
you think about it for a moment i've got
a nice cartoon view of the solar system
here i should stress absolutely not to
scale
things are much further apart than this
planet's much smaller you've got the
earth going around the sun if we were
just to take our our satellite and
launch it out into space and put it onto
its own independent orbit around the sun
that would be fine because that would
keep it a reasonable distance away from
the earth but of course the problem is
the earth and your satellite would then
go round the sun at different speeds as
you go away from the sun because the
pull of gravity gets weaker the speed at
which things orbit decreases it's one of
kepler's laws um so actually the the
satellite that was out here would get
left behind and so you'd have all these
problems that you know sometimes your
earth would be over here and the
satellite would be over here and they
wouldn't be able to communicate with
each other so what you want to do
somehow is find an orbit which puts your
satellite a decent distance away from
the earth
but also kind of keeps station with the
earth as the two orbit around the sun so
a geostationary satellite is where
you've got something which stays above
the same point on the earth so if you've
got the earth orbiting earth rotating
around then a geostationary satellite
just stays directly above the same point
on the earth because it's going around
at the same speed as the earth is
rotating this is on the bigger scale
this is where you're going around the
sun you want your satellite to be going
around the sun that's sort of the same
speed that the earth's going around the
sun you pointed out if things are a
different distance from the sun they
have to move at different speeds that's
true but there's a subtlety here which
is that actually what you're doing isn't
the two body problems so the two body
problems if you have the sun and
something in orbit around it what you're
actually doing is a three body problem
you've got the sun you've got the earth
and you've got your satellite now it's a
thing called the restricted three body
problem which means you forget about the
mass of the satellite compared to the
mass of the earth and the sun but the
earth and the sun both have mass and
that means that they both contribute
gravity and so the force that you have
to think about isn't just the force of
the sun it's the force of the
combination of the earth's gravity and
the sun's gravity and by putting things
in just the right places you can make
those two forces conspire to keep your
satellite in just the right place for
satellites like herschel and various
other satellites out there and the james
webb space telescope which hasn't yet
been launched they're going to go to a
point called the l2 point which is out
here
and this point if you think about what
the pools of gravity is doing the sun is
pulling you that way the earth is
pulling you that way so both of them are
tugging you in the same direction so the
net pull on a satellite here is stronger
than just the pull of the sun so that
contributes the extra gravity you need
to keep the satellite traveling at the
right speed to keep up with the earth so
it's not that far away from the air and
even that what i've just shown you
wasn't a scale it's about so the
distance between the earth and the sun
is about 150 million kilometers and this
l2 point is one and a half million
kilometers so it's like one percent of
the distance to the sun so actually in
terms of the scale of the solar system
it's still very small but it's sort of
four times further than the moon is from
the earth so in terms of the scale of
the earth moon system it's quite a long
way away so there's another point just
inside the earth's orbit called l1
where there the natural tendency would
be for your object to travel faster
because it's closer to the sun the pull
of gravity's stronger so it would kind
of overtake the earth but now you've got
the pull of gravity of the sun that way
the pull of gravity of the earth that
way the net effect of that is to weaken
the total force on the object which
means that it travels more slowly around
the sun so again it will keep station
with the with the earth as it goes
around there's kind of a subtlety here
that you probably don't actually want to
sit absolutely at the lagrange point for
example one real disadvantage of being
right at the l2 point if you think about
it if you had a satellite here you want
to have radio communications between the
earth and your satellite but every time
there's a solar flare which gives out
radio waves that's going to interfere
with your communications so you don't
really want to be pointing your your
radio communication disc not only at the
earth but also at the sun behind it so
typically you actually end up on an
orbit which kind of oscillates around
the lagrange point so the herschel
satellite was on quite a big orbit kind
of oscillating around which actually
kept it out of that exact line so that's
l1 in there l2 out there l3
is kind of the anti-earth it's kind of
this uh the other side of the solar
system and again something here again
you can see the net pull of the earth
and the sun is all nicely lined up which
will keep it in an orbit basically
following following the earth around
there used to be lots of science fiction
stories about l3 it used to be a popular
place to put the anti-earth or you know
if you're an evil genius that's where
you put your hidden layer because it was
always hidden behind the sun as the two
kind of orbit around each other we've
now had enough satellites out there that
have actually looked at the other side
of the solar system actually there isn't
anything much at l3 this isn't a point
that scientists or astronomers have
utilized for any reason not at all i
mean it's quite hard to get there
because it's kind of on the other side
of the solar system and of course you
would always have the sun between you
and the earth which means that actually
if you wanted to communicate with the
earth it would be a bit of a pain but if
you wanted for example one hypothesized
use for l3 is if you wanted to predict
when there were solar storms coming
around it would be very useful to be
able to look at kind of the far side of
the sun because then as the sun rotates
around anything that was going to be a
big solar eruption or whatever what have
you we would have kind of advanced
warning because we'd be able to see it
when it was on the far side of the sun
rather than when it could have sort of
arrived on our side of the sun okay so
we've got l4 and l5 now they're the sort
of slightly too subtle ones l4 is over
here and l5 is over here okay so if you
look at l4 so this is the one that's
sort of ahead of the earth so the
earth's coming around this way this is
stays permanently ahead of the earth if
you again if you think about the net
pool of gravity do you get the pull of
sun that way the pull of the earth much
weaker that way the net effect is
instead of being pulled directly towards
the sun
it's pulled a little bit that way
and so actually this an object here
actually orbits around a point somewhere
around here rather than the centre of
the sun
but actually that's what you want
because in fact the earth and the sun
are dancing around this point as well
it's the center of gravity of the
earth's sun system so the earth and the
sun you tend to think of the earth going
around and the sun stationary actually
they're not the sun's kind of doing its
own little orbits as the earth going
around this much bigger circle they're
both orbiting around this point and now
this uh something at this lagrange point
this l4 point here would also be
orbiting around the same point so again
it'll keep exactly in station and just
the same for the l5 point over here that
it's pulled towards exactly this point
these don't have much use in the earth
sun context but actually
there are other pairs of objects you
could think about and one that people
quite often look at is jupiter in the
sun because jupiter is the biggest other
body in the solar system and if you
think about jupiter and the sun as your
two bodies then actually there are a
whole bunch of objects which are kind of
trapped at the l4 and the l5 points
they're called greek and trojan
asteroids generically they're called
trojan asteroids i don't quite
understand why
things would accumulate there but they
don't accumulate at the earth's l4 and
l5 in principle they could end up
collecting at the lagrange points of
other planets as well l4 and l5 they
don't actually collect a l1 l2 and l3
because it turns out those orbits are
actually unstable so something if you
put something at say l2 and then just
left it alone
over time it would drift away the
perturbations of the other planets and
its own little motions would mean that
over time it drifted away from that
point so it's called an unstable point
and in fact if you want to put your
satellite at l2 you actually have to
have it actively controlled you have to
have rockets that kind of keep it there
very not very much but just enough to
kind of stop it from drifting away
whereas l4 and l5 are actually stable
points which means that when stuff is
there it stays there a little
perturbation it won't actually move away
from the l4 or l5 point which means over
time stuff just kind of collects there
and once it's there it stays there and
in fact the earth moon system has them
as well so there are lagrange points for
the earth moon system and people have
started to find small bodies trapped at
the lagrange points the l4 and the l5
points of the earth moon system so any
pair of objects
where in the region where those two
objects are the sort of the dominant
source of gravity so in the case of the
earth moon system sort of within the
orbit of the moon um you can find these
lagrange points and these these kind of
trapping effects occur some of the moons
i think i can't remember if it's the
moons of saturn or jupiter but some of
them actually have smaller moons trapped
at their their own lagrange points
around the planet and so on so there's
lots and lots of places with little
garage points come up
detailed pictures of this really
spectacular object but here we see what
it looked like to astronomers of the day
and they didn't know what it was
so today we're at the mercator telescope
on the island of la palma now you can
see out to the bottom of la palma in the
ocean you take a picture of a star
cluster you wait a decade or so and then
you take another picture and you see how
far the stars moved